better
internet
foragers is a documentary highlighting
how Israel prevents Palestinians from
picking wild herbs it's one of 24
Palestinian films competing for the
Sunbird award during the Palestine
cinnamonies Festival
voicing visual memory is the festival's
theme this year the festival also aims
to promote Palestinian Film Production
and provide a stage for Palestinian
narratives
no one can tell our story like we can
imagine a Hollywood movie discussing
issues of Native Americans it would be
whitewashing no matter the treatment
narrative or terminology used the most
important question remains who is
producing the image
Palestinians say they are rarely given a
platform to tell their own stories and
when their stories do reach
International audiences it usually
Israeli filmmakers who tell them
participants in this Workshop say
they're reclaiming The Narrative they
take Israeli movies and reconstruct them
from their own perspective what we
wanted to do with these films is not
just to criticize what was wrong and
what was right but rather to to think
how can we say our narrative what is how
can we use these films as an as
important archival material in narrating
our story pro-israeli views still
dominate the public sphere recently
Marvel Studios announced it will feature
an Israeli superhero in the new Captain
America movie it's insulted my
grandmother they may not be Blockbusters
but Palestinians are slowly making their
debuts internationally social media and
celebrities speaking up have given them
a space mainstream media can't or won't
many directors here tell us that while
the Palestinian narrative is being
showcased more on International screens
it still has a long way to go they say
the Israeli film industry has the
funding and access to International red
carpet making it very difficult for
Palestinians to compete
Ibrahim al-jazeera the occupied Westbank